[Musique]
ces polices comme hank et je vous ai
vécu ici officiers ambrogio je suis du
28e commissariat et une stack à ce qu'on
vient de recevoir un appel depuis la 7e
avenue qui est mature le boulevard adam
clayton et un suis un homme armé vend de
la drogue devant l'entrée il est une
veste beige attendait une veste beige et
je sais sa veste beige c'est ce à quoi
d'autre c'est tout ce qu'on sait si les
blancs noirs ou portoricain n'en sais
rien probablement noir mais ça n'a pas
été précisée c'est à cause d'un appel
téléphonique au 911 à que j'ai été
condamnées entre 25 ans et perpétuité
j'ai su corse
juste parce que j'avais une veste beige
de la même couleur que celle d'un gars
qui avait tiré sur un officier de police
[Musique]
et
on est insolent chasse je m'appelle
outils johnson je viens de sortir de
prison corps fort j'y ai passé 41 ans
homme singe et 73 ans à l'ag été arrêté
pour tentative de meurtre pour quelque
chose que je n'ai pas fait et deux
furent 2 vous vous sentez comme si on
vous avait surpris on un instant alors
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je me lève habituellement à 4 heures ou
4 heures 30 ans mosley
je suis musulman donc je fais ma prière
le matin trois hommes et deux femmes ont
fait cinq prières par jour dès l abord
en cfa puis entre 5h30 et 6h il s'est tu
à part ça je me prépare à aller dans la
cour pour faire des arts martiaux
la plupart du temps je m'habille comme
un ninja tout en noir
[Musique]
je suis allé à hong kong à l'âge de 17
ans je pratique les arts martiaux le
kung fu est le tai chi dans nba
il y a des styles différents et moi
j'avais choisi le style du chat je
pratiquais des mouvements censées imiter
cet animal malade j'ai fait 40 ans de
prison
ma demande de libération conditionnelle
a été refusée dix fois atteint je pense
que mes entraînements en arts martiaux
m'ont aidé à survivre en prison ça va
j'ai été arrêté le 5 mai 1975
mais le fais je rentrais du parc maurice
où j'enseignais les arts martiaux à des
enfants et voilà qu quand je suis sortie
du parc le cas sur les flics sont
arrivés par derrière
ils m'ont poussé contre le mur en disant
on vous arrête parce que vous
correspondez à la description d'un homme
à la baisse beige dassin heads est le
seul élément qu'on a eu comme
signalement au 911
[Musique]
j'ai protesté je viens de sortir du parc
comment vous avez l'impression que j'ai
une arme sur moi vous voyez la poudre ou
autre chose
tout ce que je porte une tenue d'arts
martiaux ah ouais j'avais un manteau en
cuir mais je leur ai montré ce que
j'avais en dessous regardez c'est un
kimono au décès ils ont dit qu'ils
avaient reçu un appel du 911 corp cède
et que la police recherchait un homme
qui avait ouvert le feu et qui était
vêtu d'une veste beige
ils n'ont rien dit quant à la race rien
de plus il voulait arrêter quelqu'un
parce qu'un officier s'était fait tirer
dessus ou s'est effectuée on veut
prouver s'il arrive quelque chose à un
officier de police
ils recherchent en premier un
afro-américain forment un corps noir
afro américains ou hispanique dont les
vêtements correspondrait à la
description rose n donc dans mon cas il
avait des témoins ce tome cède d'hadès
et deux d'entre eux ont dit qu'ils
avaient vu un homme courir dans la rue
qui fuyait la police mais ils étaient
dégarnies comme moi je le suis
aujourd'hui
et à l'époque j'avais encore beaucoup de
cheveux au cours de l'audience
mon avocat a même dit au tribunal vous
savez qu'il a été mentionné dans ce
signalement que le délinquant était
quasiment choses en cause et il n'a que
25 ans qu'il n'a pas de calvitie ils
n'ont pas répondu à cette question
l'audace mais c'est new york c'est le
système de justice pénale vous voyez non
s'ils le souhaitent ils vous mettront en
prison
à force d'appeler mon premier jour en
prison était malade j'ai médité sur la
situation sur tout ce qui s'était passé
je ne pouvais pas le croire
il m'avait jugé coupable sans aucune
preuve je me suis mis à pleurer parce
que c'est quelque chose qui vous affecte
beaucoup à coeur peu importe à quel
point vous êtes forts vont finissez par
fleuret quand vous vous retrouvez seul
en cellule
ao ça je travaillais à l'hôpital de la
prison
je pense que c'était à wana van damme a
du chien
j'ai rencontré là bas un jeune homme qui
me ressemblait un peu sonné il racontait
à l'un de ses compagnons de cellule
codétenus comment ils avaient attaqué
deux policiers en tout cas je suis allé
lui parler
j'ai demandé qu'est ce que tu as fait un
choix il m'a dit j'ai tiré sur la 7e
avenue en 75 son complice a tiré en
l'air
le policier s'est retourné et j'ai tiré
j'ai juste fait ce que j'avais à faire
pour échapper à la police
je lui ai dit tu sais quoi j'ai été
accusé de ce crime
il a répondu
merde tu me ressemble un peu je suis
désolé mais que veux tu que je fasse je
lui ai dit seulement si tu le veux coup
le peu fait des aveux complets raconte
que c'est toi qui a fait sa une au ras
des jets ajouté tu sais j'ai déjà fait
30 ans alors il a répondu ouais d'accord
nous en parlerons une autre fois je lui
ai proposé de se revoir la bibliothèque
le samedi il était d'accord
voilà mais il n'est jamais venu
[Musique]
à gauche je vais à mon audience et là on
me dit si vous avouez que vous avez
commis ce crime
vous serez libéré vous êtes bien
comportés vous avez obtenu une
qualification et un diplôme et vous
n'avez jamais été impliquées dans des
bagarres
rien de ce genre son nouveau relâcheront
il vous faut seulement avoué que vous
avez commis ce crime
j'ai protesté non je ne ferai pas ça je
ne l'ait pas fait je défendrai ma cause
je continuerai à lutter pour la vérité
quand je sortirai je ne vais pas avouer
quelque chose que je n'ai jamais fait
alors ma demande a été refusée pour la
neuvième fois la dixième fois ils m'ont
relâché
[Musique]
voilà quand je suis sorti de prison ok
je ne savais pas grand chose sur la
société
on m'a déposé à times square pasqua au
42ème rue avec un petit sac à dos les
deux tickets de bus et 40 dollars en
poche c'est tout
[Musique]
[Rires]
les gens avaient ces petits trucs dans
les oreilles je pensais vraiment que
c'était des agents de la cia ou du fbi
haye qui travaillait sous couverture
comme à la télé vous voyez toutes ces
histoires de flics incroyable autre
chose par exemple la nourriture des
trucs comme ça vous savez je vous ai
déjà parlé du beurre de cacahuète avec
la confiture
moi je n'avais jamais vu personne
mélanger du beurre de cacahuète avec de
la confiture et ça m'a plu c'est la junk
food inc
et puis il rajoute de la glace là dessus
ah la vache ça me rendait fou banane
cerise tout ce qu'on veut regarder tout
ce battage autour d'eux c'est quoi le
mourant l'astor ça claude autour du
harcèlement sexuel voilà il ya tous ces
gens qui sortent de nulle part pour
accuser quelqu'un de harcèlement dont
est atteint moi je crois que la plupart
des dénonciateurs font ça pour l'argent
je ne pense pas que tous les accusés
aient vraiment fait ça écoute tu te
souviens avoir été violée ou forcés à
coucher avec quelqu'un il ya 50 ans
et c'est maintenant que tu en parles et
pas seulement ça
guay il y a des gays qui ressemble à des
femmes
on peut à peine faire la différence mais
ça m'a beaucoup choqué aussi j'étais
désemparée quand une dame que je connais
ma 10e
je t'ai vu sourire à cette jeune femme
n'est ce pas j'ai dit oui et elle est
jolie et elle m'a répondu que c'était un
homme
moi j'étais genre c'est pas vrai ça ne
peut pas être un homme mais ce qui m'a
le plus frappé saadé oise c'est de voir
que le respect mutuel avait beaucoup
disparaissent quand c'est devenue
dangereuse
je voudrais vraiment que les gens
retrouvent une conscience morale
même de petites choses feront comprendre
que nous avons besoin de montrer plus de
respect les uns envers les autres fois
lynch mob de temps en temps je parle
sans abri comme ce type là je leur donne
quelques dollars et je leur demande si
tout va bien
[Musique]
comment allez-vous aujourd'hui bien vous
pourquoi ne voulez-vous pas aller dans
un refuge
je ne suis pas dans un refuge oui mais
je demande pourquoi vous ne voulez pas y
aller pourquoi je ne vais pas dans un
refuge je vois beaucoup de gens dans les
rues
et ils préfèrent rester dans la rue
plutôt que d'aller dans un refuge et je
leur en parle je n'ai pas besoin de
refuge j'ai une chambre juste à côté je
vois vous allez bien alors tenez bon
[Musique]
le pire ou pour ainsi dire l'effet
secondaire d'un long séjour en prison
c'est qu'on acquiert ce qu'on appelle la
mentalité du prisonnier où les habitudes
du prisonnier
quand je prends une douche un watch moi
je lave mes vêtements et sous-vêtements
ma chemise peut-être mon pantalon
je lave tout sous la douche n savez vous
pourquoi
picross parce que j'ai appris à faire ça
en prison eh bien je me suis habitué
c'est une forme de stress post
traumatique il y as a way mais aussi mes
habitudes alimentaires quand je suis
arrivé en prison j'ai appris ce que
c'était que la junk food
zhang fou qu'un dd bonbon quand du pop
corn solde du soda cause d'abord parce
que on n'a que 15 à 35 cents par jour
toi tu allais face à des rockets une
mercedes n'est pas vraiment assez pour
acheter de bons mais maintenant j'achète
des conserves de la junk food fou à de
la crème glacée des gâteaux des bonbons
des coupes jusqu'à ou comme et pourquoi
ne pas acheter un morceau de viande pour
une grillade est une cause c'est parce
que je me suis habitué à ne pas acheter
de viande bas mais on classe à adobe et
puis je n'ai pas trop d'argent
de toute ma vie moi je n'ai eu qu'une
seule relation sexuelle j'avais 16 ans
je crois dawa sac et c'était la seule
fois
je
à ce jour je n'ai pas eu d'autres
relations sexuelles à samos wa dongo ça
fait plus de 50 ans que je n'ai pas
coucher avec une femme
le temps que j'ai passé à hong kong m'a
aidé à me discipliner à m'écarter de mes
désirs
par exemple je ne me drogue pas je n'ai
jamais été défoncée il y a beaucoup de
femmes qui me demandent de sortir avec
elle de passer la nuit avec elle vous
d'aller au cinéma et je cherche toujours
des excuses comme âge est un rendez vous
j'ai du travail
vous savez qu'on me débarrasser de ces
femmes vous croyez que vous pourriez
encore avoir une relation avec une femme
oui je pense que je pourrais que j'ai
peur de l as to me demande souvent n'es
tu pas en colère face à ce qui t'es
arrivé tu as fait quarante ans de prison
pour quelque chose que tu n'as pas fait
est tu n'es pas en colère jeudi
en quoi la colère mais de rethel qu'est
ce qui ressortirait de ma colère ne
croyez-vous pas que je survivrai mieux
si j'oublie le passé et vais de l'avant
à
[Musique]
pas
o o
a loupé mais ricky ouais comme en vain
c'est otis tu sais où ma mère a été
enterré au bon dieu
je crois que c'est sugar hill ah oui
c'est ce que je pensais mieux quand
c'est parce que je voudrais y aller tu
comprends oui elle est enterrée sur la
colline si je me trompe pas c'est asbury
park ou à neptune un neptune
adacore coeur ouais enfin sur la colline
d'accord tu pourrais vérifier ses
informations pour mot ce peuple est
d'accord ok merci mon frère
ans
[Musique]
on va à neptune ou asbury park
selon ce que m'a dit hier mon cousin
ricky
m
là où toute ma famille est enterré et je
pense que je me souviendrai du chemin
il a dit que c'était sugar hill elles
pourraient être enterrés là bas comme
tous les membres de ma famille à sugar
hill à neptune
[Musique]
la dernière fois que j'ai parlé à ma
mère c'était à la fin des années 90 ou
en 2001 elle m'a alors dit qu'elle ne
pouvait plus continuer ce terroir elle
ne pouvait plus écrire ou me parler au
téléphone mais un enfant tout cas parce
que c'était trop dur pour elle ça m'a
beaucoup blessée surtout quand on est en
prison et que votre mère vous annonce
je ne veux plus entendre parler de toi
aucune raison cg koch juste parce que
vous êtes incarcéré c'est à ce moment là
que votre mère est censé rester à vos
côtés vous encourager surtout si elle
sait que vous êtes innocent il ya du
monde
j'habite à ici autrefois asbury pas moi
aussi vous aussi
dis donc je viens de rentrer à la maison
après 40 ans de prison
je suis désolé je cherche la tombe de ma
mère elle est peut-être intérêt à 33 sur
la colline et et puis un autre cimetière
en face du centre commercial
je devais rencontrer mon cousin ici mais
il n'est pas venu
je suis désolé pour vous
on
[Musique]
bloguer
chargé c'est de te joindre depuis le
début de la journée
[Musique]
non non elle n'a pas décroché j'ai
appelé au ciri qui il devait me rappeler
à 16 heures et ben oui il a dit qu'il ne
savait rien et à les appeler sa mère
alma oui oui mais il ne m'a pas rappelé
voilà donc je suis à ce bris parc en ce
moment c'est ok merci sahara
la famille désunie dans ces ridicules
il n'y a aucune excuse à cela je ne sais
pas comment faire face à tout ça c'est
pénible
personne ne sait rien
les uns disent que ma mère est ici
d'autres qu'elle est là bas et je leur
ai dit que j'étais asbury park et ils
vivent près d'ici conques où elles ne
peuvent pas venir et m'aider à trouver
sa tombe
il reste à la maison à ne rien faire
combien de temps ça va leur prendre pour
se rendre à la maison funéraire pour
venir me rejoindre
ou tout simplement me parler de ma mère
je ne sais pas
non
je suis désolé excusez moi
je suis la maman
juste ici personne ne viendra
[Musique]
je veux voir ma mère maintenant je suis
là
[Musique]
cela m'a vraiment blessé
de voir de telles choses dans ma propre
famille je comprends aujourd'hui
vraiment ce que les autres ressentent
quand il me parle de situation pareille
tout ce qui concerne les proches la
famille la maison heures il n'y a plus
de respect tout ce qu'ils veulent c'est
de l'argent que de l'argent
[Musique]
je dois dire que tout ce qui arrive dans
la vie arrive pour une raison
j'estime vraiment que j'ai été mis en
prison parce que j'ai été choisi pour
raconter aux gens de mon art et leur
montrer ce que j'avais vécu et sans
faille pour leur faire comprendre ce qui
se passe dans la société
[Musique]
donc je pense que c'est la mission de ma
vie
[Musique]